first nathan asked this what about y
equals x
cubed okay
now again you're a bit sick of it but
i'm going to try a table of values
right don't worry i'll do the numbers
for you i promise i won't work your
brain too hard okay
x y i'm gonna do the same numbers
you see why this is such a useful tool
it does take a while
but it gives you results that you can't
argue with and then you can draw a shape
off it right
okay again we'll start with the positive
numbers because they're a bit easier
zero
cubed is zero
one cubed is one okay
two cubed two cubed
two cubed is two times two
times two again it's eight good
very good and and okay now now think
carefully let's go the other way
but watch out there's a minus sign there
right
so when you cube it it's going to become
negative 1 times negative 1 times
negative 1 that's what
cubing means right multiply three times
so what's gonna happen um these two
negatives will cancel
and that's just good but you'll be left
with one of them right
okay two negatives become
a positive and then you're gonna get
negative a
so look at this if i just plot this now
this is the shape that you get it's a
pretty cool shape
this is y equals x cubed weird kind of
shape
if you just look at one side it looks
like x squared doesn't it
but the other side looks like minus x
squared it's upside
down right and that's because when you
cube negative numbers you still get
negatives
whereas when you square negative numbers
right
when you square them they're always
positive yeah i don't understand how in
the table it goes like
minus eight and minus how you got that
these two values
yeah yeah okay so let's come back to
this value because i've written that one
down
okay what happens here i tried out x
equals minus one
okay so i put in minus one there where
the x is
does that make sense still with me yes
okay
so now i just wrote that out this is
minus one
cubed minus one times minus one times
minus one three times
that's what cubed means yeah but
see these two negatives these two
negatives the two negatives when you
multiply them they just
cancel each other out two negatives make
a positive don't they
so this guy you don't have to worry
about it and then you're just left with
that negative one
okay now you can rehearse the same thing
with this right
negative 2. it's going to be negative 2
times negative 2
times negative 2. okay again two
negatives
again it's going to cancel and you get 2
times 2 times
negative 2 which is negative 8.
hence this value okay
so the twos don't disappear it's the
negatives that disappear the negatives
cancel each other
okay it's like
4 times negative two yes
that's exactly what it is it's exactly
right uh uh
these two they the negatives cancel and
they you just left with the two times
two which is the four
times negative two gives you negative
eight okay
good spot all right very last one
uh just for a bit of fun when i put my
reason
uh the question was what happens if if
the x is first instead of a y
this will spin you out a little bit and
i'm just going to put it up there and
not make too much comment on it unless
you want me to
here's what we're looking at x equals y
squared instead of
y equals x squared so i've swapped them
around okay it's going to be sideways
ah
it's sideways sure enough and the
question is why
does this work or is the question y
squared anyway sorry um so
so here's the way that i would think
about it here's a short way of thinking
about it right
when you get y equals x squared you have
this parabola shape
okay now if you swap the x's and y's
what that means is you look at this
shape and you turn your head
sideways right to swap the x's and y's
so this becomes your vertical axis
and that's the way the problem's going
and this is your horizontal one
because the x and y is swapped
horizontal and vertical have
swapped which means you look at it like
this and you're like that's the parabola
i
got before it's just sideways
you can also i'm not going to do it
because we've done it 50 million times
you can also draw up a table of values
and sure enough
this is what you'll get okay um
why don't you think you have anything
here why is nothing going over because
people will be there
so what why aren't there negatives
though like you're right but why the
negatives are on the left-hand side
while positive is on the right and the
question has no negatives
because but why not why not
i'll show you i'll show you why let's
try x equals a negative number give me a
negative number any number you like
minus
73 minus five minus five minus seven
so i'm going to try x equals minus five
x equals minus five
right so every instead of x i'm gonna
write minus 1. so minus 5
equals y squared so that means okay
what number when you square it gives you
negative 5.
and the answer is well okay
you try a positive number if you square
it you won't get a negative
if you try a um i rubbed it off if you
try a negative number and you square it
you'll still get
a positive number you'll never get a
negative number there's none of these
numbers you can try
not on this graph you need to draw a new
graph um that will work
right so you can never put in a negative
value of x it just
kind of explodes you can be sitting on
your calculator for
all day putting numbers into y and
you'll never get minus five